amelia team ist mir jetzt zugeschaltet
muss er ja immer viele mögen sie was
fühlen sie wenn sie zurückdenken an den
dezember 2016 ich spüre schmerz ein
leben hat sich tatsächlich verändert
durch diese nacht durch diese tat und
was ich jetzt aber es ist einfach
passiert damals
es schmerzt
alles hat sich verändert
ich erinnere mich nicht an viel sei aus
dem aber was ich erlebt habe
schmerzhaft bleibt bei mir was bleibt
bei mir hängen in diese aus dieser nacht
das ist es sie und ihre familie
ich kann mir vorstellen wie sehr sie
gelitten haben
wie wichtig war es für sie nach dem
anschlag zusammen zu stehen als familie
ich bin der einzige überlebt hat also
der für meine kinder überlebt hat die
familie zusammenhalten und das versuche
ich das mache ich das mache ist er seit
jenem tag seit jenem nacht
ich bin bei meinen kindern und ich
unterstütze sie
ich gebe meinen kindern was sie brauchen
aber sie habe ihre mutter verloren
das ist eine ist sehr tragisch sei ein
großer verlust für sie und für mich
natürlich ihre kinder haben ja ihre
mutter so beliebt dass vermissen sie am
meisten wo würden sie ihre hilfe
brauchen wo vermissen sie am meisten
wann jeden tag von mir sagt sie jeden
moment vermisse ich sehe ist in gedanken
bei mir leid und ich muss damit leben
damit auskommen das ist das los
diesen verlust ertrag für meine kinder
jetzt ja bitte herzlichen dank der sich
die zeit genommen haben danken dass sie
so ehrlich darüber gesprochen haben über
diesen dramatischen anschlag alles gute
für sie und ihre familie danke ihnen
erst jetzt am breitscheidplatz er hat
auch vor vier jahren damals berichtet
als der anschlag passierte es matthias
auch an sich die frage welche bilder
welche erinnerungen kommen in der hoch
wenn du jetzt da stehst wo all das vor
vier jahren passiert ist
ja hallo isabella ich stehe hier wo vor
vier jahren damals der furchtbaren
anschlag des islamistischen attentäters
eines amri passiert ist der attentäter
hatte zuvor den lkw gekapert den
sattelschlepper und ist dann hier von
der hardenberg straße aus richtung
bahnhof kommt auf den 3 platz gefahren
hier sehen wir jetzt poller das war
damals nicht so gesichert zu dem
zeitpunkt war hier der weihnachtsmarkt
der jetzt normalerweise ja auch wäre
durch corona nicht und ich war durch
super hier gerade in der nähe erreichen
der nähe gewohnt habe kurz wenige
minuten nach dem anschlag sozusagen
anruf aus der redaktion erhalten wenn
ihr sofort her und es war wirklich ein
gespenstisches beängstigendes bild ich
habe viel erlebt als reporter aber hier
lagen menschen verletzt auf dem boden
hier war alles abgesperrt
obwohl der anschlag zu dem zeitpunkt als
ich hergekommen bin vielleicht zehn oder
fünfzehn jürgen herr war überall
feuerwehr der sattelschlepper stand hier
mitten in dem weihnachtsmarkt in den
buden drin
er ist wirklich hier mit vollgas in die
menschenmenge rheingas hier standen
menschen ja den glühwein getrunken haben
ihre bratwurst gegessen haben sich
amüsiert in dem moment ist völlig
unvermittelt dieser härte schlepper
herein gerast hier sind menschen auf dem
boden betreut worden verletzte verarztet
worden zu dem zeitpunkt wusste man ja
noch nicht dass es sich um einen
anschlag handelt das hat sich dann
später herausgestellt aber auch im laufe
des abends ist eine sehr beeindrucken
wird auch drückende situation und es war
sie eine sehr kalte nacht und
man hat trotzdem gemerkt dass die
menschen die dann hier her gekommen sind
an teilgenommen haben und ist ein genie
berliner hergekommen um sich das
anzusehen was hier passiert ist und es
war wie gesagt einer der bedrückendsten
augenblick in meiner in meinem
journalistischen matthias jetzt sehe ich
hinter dir sehr sehr viele kerzen die
aufgestellt sind wird es heute eine art
gedenkveranstaltung geben trotz corona
ja es wird erzählt kaiser wilhelm
gedächtniskirche wird es um 19 uhr wird
es einen gedenkgottesdienst geben
hier sind tatsächlich kerzen aufgestellt
grabkerzen wie jedes jahr eigentlich
hier kommen auch ganz viele menschen
herrn zünden kerzen an oder legten
blumen nieder
für angehörige oder für menschen die sie
gekannt haben oder auch diese nicht
gekannt haben weil sie einfach
teilnehmen oder anteil nehmen an diesen
schrecklichen vorfall und mitgefühl
haben es wird dann um 20 uhr zwei zum
zeitpunkt des anschlages wird es zwölf
glockenschläge geben für die zwölf
todesopfer also hier auf dem
breitscheidplatz sind elf menschen
gestorben
aus deutschland das kokain aus der
tschechischen republik aber auch aus
israel wie die frauen des
gesprächspartners eben und natürlich der
polnische lkw-fahrer der von alessandro
erschossen worden ist bevor dann andere
sozusagen sein sattelschlepper gekapert
hat und dann hier auf dem rad gefahren
ist also um 20.02 wenn hier zwölf
glockenschläge tönen für die zwölf
getöteten opfer und auch für die rund
100 teilweise zu schwer verletzten
menschen die hier
ob er dieses terroristischen anschlags
geworden sind
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren